principles for success an ultra mini
series adventure in 30 minutes and in
eight episodes
episode one
the call to adventure
before we begin let me just establish
the fact that i don't know much relative
to what i need to know
whatever success i've had in life has
more to do with my knowing how to deal
with my not knowing than anything i know
that i should be telling other people
what to do sounds kind of presumptuous
to me but i'm going to do it because i
believe that the principles that have
made me successful could help others
achieve their own goals
i'm now at a stage in my own life in
which it is much more important to me to
pass along what i've learned about how
to be successful than to seek more
success for myself
what you choose to do with these
principles is up to you you have to be
an independent thinker because only you
can develop your own principles based on
your own values
this brings me to my first and most
fundamental principle which is that you
need to think for yourself about what is
true so let's get started early on i
discovered i needed principles
principles are smart ways for handling
things that happen over and over again
in similar situations there are
principles for everything from skiing to
parenting to cooking and so on
i'm going to share some of my most
important overarching life principles
that influence how we approach
everything that we do
i didn't start out with principles i
acquired them over a lifetime of
experiences
mostly from making mistakes and
reflecting on them
my life principles are simple but
they're not complete
i still struggle to make the best
decisions and i still make mistakes and
learn new principles all the time
this is the reality
at the beginning i needed to escape the
conventions that surrounded me which
meant that i needed to think for myself
unless you want to have a life that is
directed by others you need to decide
for yourself what to do
and you need to have the courage to do
it
but i didn't know that at first i only
learned that from going on my adventure
looking back on my own journey i now see
the time is like a river that carries us
forward into encounters with reality
that require us to make decisions
we can't stop our movement down this
river
and we can't avoid the encounters
we can only approach them in the best
possible way
in your lifetime you will face millions
of decisions the quality of your
decisions will determine the quality of
your life
over the course of my lifetime the most
valuable things i've learned were the
results of mistakes i reflected on to
help form principles so i wouldn't make
the same mistakes again these principles
took me from being a very ordinary
middle class kid from long island to
becoming very successful as judged by
conventional measures they also gave me
the meaningful work and meaningful
relationships that i value even more
than these conventional successes
people often ask me how i did it i can
assure you it wasn't because of my
uniqueness as a person it was the result
of a unique approach to life i believe
almost anybody can adopt
it starts with embracing reality and
dealing with it
the path you take in life is your most
important decision
in my case i wanted my life to be great
and i feared boredom and mediocrity more
than i feared failure
since i didn't start out with money and
i didn't need much more than a bed to
sleep in and food to eat i could skew my
decisions to pursue my adventures so
ever since i was a kid i ran after the
things i wanted
crashed got up and ran again
and crashed again
and each time i crashed i learned
something got better and crashed less
by doing that over and over again i
learned to love this process even the
crashing part of it
through it i encountered reality
and i learned how to deal with it which
inspired another one of my most
fundamental principles which is that
truth is the essential foundation for
producing good outcomes
by truth i don't mean anything more than
the way the world works
i believe that we were given the laws of
reality by nature humans didn't create
them but we can use them to foster our
own evolution and achieve our goals
realizing that made me a hyper realist
by which i mean i became someone who has
discovered the great rewards of deeply
understanding accepting and working with
reality as it is and not as i wish it
would be
when i say i'm a hyper realist people
sometimes think i'm saying that dreams
can't come true
that's absolutely not true
without pursuing dreams life is mundane
what i mean is that to me hyper realism
is the best way to choose one's dreams
and then achieve them
having big dreams plus embracing reality
plus having lots of determination will
bring you a successful life
i believe this formula is true for
everyone but what does a successful life
look like we each have to decide for
ourselves what success is
i don't care whether you want to be a
master of the universe or to live under
a palm tree or anything else i really
don't
each of us chooses goals based on our
values and decides on the best path to
achieve them
but we all need approaches to making
decisions that work well especially when
facing problems mistakes and weaknesses
that stand in our way
to succeed we must embrace all our
realities especially the harsh realities
that we wish weren't true
at first looking at these harsh
realities caused me a lot of pain but i
learned that this pain was just
psychological and that my seeing things
differently made all the difference i
came to view problems like puzzles that
would reward me if i could solve them
they would help me deal with the problem
at hand and they would give me
principles for dealing with similar
problems in the future
i learned to treat pain as a cue that a
great learning opportunity is at hand
which led me to realize
that pain plus reflection equals
progress
meditation has been invaluable in
helping me see things that way
i found that when i calmed myself down
and embraced my realities and dealt with
them
the rewards brought me pleasure and the
pain faded each of us has the unique
capability to think logically to reflect
on ourselves and our circumstances and
to direct our own personal evolution
doing this well is just a matter of
following a simple five-step process
we've discussed how important it is to
reflect carefully after experiencing
pain
when i did this i was usually able to
discover principles that would prevent
me from repeating the same mistakes in
the future
and i could see that being successful
simply consisted of five steps
step one is to know your goals and run
after them what is best for you depends
on your nature so you need to really
understand yourself and know what you
want to achieve in life
step two is to encounter the problems
that stand in the way of getting to your
goals
these problems are typically painful if
handled badly some of them can lead to
your ruin
but to evolve you need to identify those
problems and not tolerate them
step three is to diagnose these problems
to get at their root causes
don't jump too quickly to solutions take
a step back and reflect in order to
really distinguish the symptoms from the
disease
step four is to design a plan to
eliminate the problems
this is where you will determine what
you need to do to get around them
and step five is to execute those
designs pushing yourself to do what's
needed to progress toward your goal
a successful life essentially consists
of doing these five steps over and over
again this is your personal evolution
and you see this process everywhere
it's just a law of nature think of any
product any organization or any person
you know and you will see that this is
true for them
evolution is simply a process of either
adapting or dying
conceptually it looks just like the five
step process i've described
as you push through this often painful
process
you'll naturally ascend to higher and
higher levels of success
i found that when i did it better my
struggling never became easier because
the more capable i became the greater
the challenges i would take on
because different people are strong and
weak at different things most people
can't do all five steps well
not facing this reality means you could
stretch further than you should
and as the heights get greater your
falls could also be greater
sometimes terrible things happen to all
of us in life they can ruin us or they
can profoundly improve us depending on
how we handle them
something like this happened to me in
1982
we progress forward until we encounter
setbacks
whether or not we get out of them and
continue forward or spiral downward
depends on whether or not we're willing
to face the failure objectively and make
the right decisions to turn the loop
upward again
something terrible happened to me in
1982 when i bet everything on a
depression that never came
the period between 1979 and 1982 was one
of extreme turbulence for the global
economy the markets and for me
and i believe that the u.s economy with
the world economy tied to it was headed
toward a catastrophe
this view was extremely controversial
i wanted the great upside and very
publicly took a big risk and was wrong
dead raw
after a delay the stock market began a
big bull market that lasted 18 years and
the u.s economy enjoyed the greatest
growth period in its history
this experience was like a blow to my
head with a baseball bat
i had to cut my losses so that my
company bridgewater was left with one
employee
me
i was so broke i had to borrow four
thousand dollars from my dad to pay my
bills
but even worse was having to let go the
people i cared so much about
i wondered whether i should give up my
dream of working for myself and play it
safe by working for someone else in a
job that would require me to put on a
tie and commute every day
though i knew that for me taking less
risk would mean having a less great life
being so wrong and especially being so
publicly wrong was painfully humbling
i am still shocked and embarrassed by
how arrogant i was
in being totally confident in a totally
incorrect view
though i'd been right much more than i'd
been wrong i had let one bad bet erase
all my good ones
i thought very hard about the
relationship between risk and reward and
how to manage them
but i couldn't see a path forward that
would give me the rewards i wanted
without unacceptable risk
this kind of experience happens to
everyone
it will happen to you
you will lose something or someone you
think you can't live without
or you will suffer a terrible illness or
injury or your career will fall apart
before your eyes
you might think that your life is ruined
and that there's no way to go forward
but it will pass
i assure you that there is always a best
path forward and you probably just don't
see it yet
you just have to reflect well to find it
you have to embrace your reality
[Music]
sometimes things happen that are hard to
understand
life often feels so difficult and
complicated it's too much to take in all
at once
my deep pain led me to reflect deeply on
my circumstances
it also led me to reflect on nature
because it provides a guide for what's
true
so i thought a lot about how things work
which helped to put me and my own
circumstances in perspective
i saw that at the big bang all the laws
and forces of the universe were created
and propelled forward interacting with
each other as a perpetual motion machine
in which all the bits and pieces
coalesce into machines that work for a
while fall apart and then coalesce into
new machines this goes on into eternity
i saw that everything is a machine the
structure and evolution of galaxies the
formation of our own solar system the
makeup of earth's geography and
ecosystems our economies and markets and
each of us we individually are machines
made up of different machines our
circulatory system our nervous system
that produce our thoughts our dreams our
emotions and all the other aspects of
our distinct characters
all of these different machines evolve
together through time to produce the
realities we encounter every day
and i realized that i was just one tiny
bit in one nanosecond deciding what i
should do
while that perspective might sound very
philosophical i found that it was very
practical because it showed me how i
could deal with my own realities in a
better way
for example i observed that most
everything happens over and over again
in slightly different ways
some in obvious short-term cycles that
are easy to recognize so we know how to
deal with them like the 24-hour day
some so infrequently that they haven't
occurred in our lifetimes and we're
shocked when they do
like the once in a hundred year storm
and some we know exist but are
encountering for the first time like the
birth of our first child
most people mistakenly treat these
situations as being unique and deal with
them without having proper perspective
or principles to help them get through
them i found that if instead of dealing
with these events as one-offs i could
see each as just another one of those
and approach them in the same way a
biologist might approach an animal first
identifying its species then drawing on
principles for dealing with it
appropriately because i could see these
events transpire in pretty much the same
ways over and over i could more clearly
see the cause affect relationships that
govern their behaviors which allowed me
to develop better principles that i
could express in both words and
algorithms i learned that while most
everyone expects the future to be a
slightly modified version of the present
it is typically very different that's
because people are biased by recent
history and overlook events that haven't
happened in a long time perhaps not even
in their lifetime but they will happen
again
with that perspective i realized that
what i missed when i mistakenly called
for a great depression was hidden in the
patterns of history
and i could use my newfound knowledge of
these patterns to make better decisions
in the future and when i thought about
my challenge balancing risk and reward i
realized that risk and reward naturally
go together i could see that to get the
most out of life one has to take more
risk
and that knowing how to appropriately
balance risk and reward is essential to
having the best life possible
imagine you are faced with the choice of
having a safe boring life if you stay
where you are or having a fabulous one
if you take the risk of successfully
crossing a dangerous jungle
that is essentially the choice we all
face
for me the choice was clear but that
doesn't mean the path forward was
without challenges
i still needed to face two big barriers
that we all must face
i can't tell you which path in life is
best for you because i don't know how
important it is for you to achieve big
goals relative to how important it is
for you to avoid the pains required to
get them
this is the courage i spoke of earlier
and we each have to feel these things
out for ourselves
after my big mistake in calling for a
depression i had come to one of life's
forks in the road as we all do
if i made the choice to take a normal
job and play it safe i would have ended
up with a very different life than the
one i had
but as long as i could pay the rent put
food on the table and educate my kids
the only choice for me was to risk
crossing the jungle in pursuit of the
best life possible
my big mistake in betting on a
depression gave me a healthy fear of
being wrong
in other words it gave me deep humility
which was exactly what i needed
at the same time it didn't stop me from
aggressively going after the things i
wanted
to succeed i needed to see more than i
alone could see
but standing in my way of doing that
were the two biggest barriers everyone
faces
are ego and blind spot barriers
these barriers exist because of how our
brains work
first let's explore the ego barrier
when i refer to your ego barrier i'm
talking about the parts of your brain
that prevent you from acknowledging your
weaknesses objectively so that you can
figure out how to deal with them
your deepest seated needs and fears
reside in areas of your brain that
control your emotions and are not
accessible to your higher level
conscious awareness
and because our need to be right can be
more important than our need to find out
what's true
we like to believe our own opinions
without properly stress testing them we
especially don't like to look at our
mistakes and weaknesses
we are instinctively prone to react to
explorations of them as though they're
attacks
we get angry even though it would be
more logical for us to be open to
feedback from others
this leads to our making inferior
decisions learning less and falling
short of our potentials
the second is the blind spot barrier
everyone has blind spots the blind spot
barrier is when a person believes he or
she can see everything but it's a simple
fact that no one alone can see a
complete picture of reality
naturally people can't appreciate what
they can't see
just as we all have different ranges for
singing hearing pitch and seeing colors
we have different ranges for seeing and
understanding things
for example while some people are better
at seeing the big picture
others excel at seeing details
some are linear thinkers and others are
more lateral
while some are creative but not reliable
others are reliable but not creative and
so on
because of how our brains are wired
differently everyone perceives the world
around them differently
by doing what comes naturally to us we
fail to account for our weaknesses and
we crash
either we keep doing that or we change
aristotle defined tragedy as a terrible
outcome arising from a person's fatal
flaw
a flaw that hadn't been fixed would have
instead led to a wonderful outcome
in my opinion these two barriers are the
main impediments that get in the way of
good decision-making
taking risks and occasionally being
ruined wasn't acceptable and neither was
not taking risks and not having
exceptional results
i needed an approach that would give me
the exceptional upside without also
giving me the exceptional downside
when i discovered it it turned out to be
my holy grail
to get it i needed to replace the joy of
being proven right with the joy of
learning what's true
this need prompted me to seek out the
most thoughtful people i could find who
disagreed with me
i didn't care about their conclusions i
just wanted to see things through their
eyes and to have them see things through
my eyes so that together we can hash
things out to discover what's true
in other words what i wanted most from
them was thoughtful disagreement
going from seeing things through just my
eyes to seeing things through the eyes
of these thoughtful people
was like going from seeing things in
black and white to seeing them in color
the world lit up
that's when i realized that the best way
to go through the jungle of life is with
insightful people who see things
differently from me
think about the five-step process i
described earlier
as i said because we are wired so
differently not everyone can do all the
five steps well
but you don't have to do them all alone
you can get help from others who are
good at what you're not who are wired to
perceive things you can't
all you need to do is let go of your
attachment to having the right answers
yourself
and use your fear of being wrong to
become open-minded to these other views
in this way you could point out the
risks and opportunities that you would
individually miss
i found that taking this radically
open-minded approach and
believability-weighting people's
thinking
significantly increased my probabilities
of making the best decisions possible
this enabled me to ascend to greater
heights and greater challenges
in the past i would have always wanted
to do what i myself thought was best but
now i sought out the strongest
independent thinkers i could find i
still do
there is nothing better to be on a
shared mission with extraordinary people
who can be radically truthful and
radically transparent with each other
this approach led me to create a company
with the unique idea meritocracy
operating in a unique way that produced
unique successes
in an idea meritocracy you get the best
of everybody
everyone thinks independently then we
work through our disagreements to get at
what's best
however not every opinion is equally
valuable and we had to learn to
distinguish between good ideas and bad
ones to get the best decisions in other
words we needed to believability weight
people's thinking
but that's another story i will explain
in my work principles
right now there are many wonderful
opportunities and dangerous risks
surrounding you that you don't see
if you saw them free of the distortions
produced by your ego or your blind spots
you would be able to deal with them more
effectively if you could acquire this
ability and with practice you can you
will radically improve your life
[Music]
so far i described how i learned to
confront my own realities my problems my
mistakes and weaknesses and how i
surrounded myself with others who could
do things better than i could
this was the most effective way i
discovered from making great decisions
this is not the normal way of being but
through this approach i became very
successful and being successful enabled
me to meet extraordinarily successful
people and see how they think i've
discovered that their journeys were
similar to mine you might not know it
but they all struggle and they all have
weaknesses that they all get around by
working with people who see risks and
opportunities that they would miss
over time i learned that by nature most
people's greatest strengths are also
connected to their most significant
weaknesses and striving hard for big
things is bound to lead you to painful
falls it's just part of the process
such setbacks will test you
they sort people
some think hard about what caused their
setbacks learn lessons and continue
progressing toward their goals
while others decide that this game is
not for them and get off the field
i've come to realize that success is not
a matter of attaining one's goals
i found that when i reached each new
higher level of success i really remain
satisfied
the things we are striving for are just
the bait
struggling to get them forces us to
evolve and it is this struggle toward
personal evolution with others that is
the reward
i no longer wanted to get across the
jungle but instead wanted to find
greater and greater challenges to go
after
surrounded by great people working
together on a shared journey
eventually the success of the mission
and the well-being of the people
alongside me became more important than
my own success
i also started to see beyond myself and
wanted others to be successful when i'm
no longer here
i realize that if i fail to do that i
will be a failure
i struggle with this now
we all struggle with different things at
different times until we either choose
to give up or until we die and become
part of the larger evolutionary story
this is how all machines work and are
recycled through time
when a machine breaks down its parts go
back into the system to become parts of
new machines that also evolve through
time
sometimes this makes us sad because we
become very attached to our machines
but if you look at it from the higher
level it's really beautiful to observe
how the machine of evolution works
now you must decide for yourself how you
will evolve
forget about where these principles came
from just assess whether or not they are
useful to you and evolve them to suit
your own needs
as with all of life's decisions what you
do with them is ultimately up to you
my only hope for you is that you have
the courage to struggle and evolve well
to make your life as great as it can be
thank you and goodbye
[Music]
you